Transcriber: Méline Adr
Reviewer: Manlin Fang
I'm Chloe and I'm a journalist, gender
equality campaigner and poet.
I'm also a feminist. I've been a feminist
for a big chunk of my life now,
nearly half of it. Now I'm 29.
I was inspired by the men and
women I grew up around,
and their beliefs shaped me, but
so did the world around me.
Feminism, to me is about gender equality
and the fight for women
and marginalised genders to have that.
It pushes against traditional gender roles
introduced by colonial powers,
which harms all members of society. Yes,
even men in power.
I believe that the world we live in is
one that needs people loudly fighting
against misogyny and trying to combat
violence against women and girls.
Because it is an epidemic.
Over my career, almost by accident,
I've become one of those people.
It often hasn't felt like a choice
because it feels so necessary.
How could I watch on and do nothing when
every minute of every day in the UK,
the police receive a phone call about
domestic violence in which 89% of
the victims are women being
abused by a man.
This summer, this need was confirmed.
We saw Kyle Clifford charged with
the murders of Carol Hannah
and Louise Hunt.
We saw the media call him a nice guy
focused more on Carol's husband than her.
They tried to say that crossbows were
the problem, not male violence.
I felt sick as I followed the
case of Giselle Pennicott,
who is currently fighting not only
her assailants but the system.
She was routinely drugged unconscious
by her husband
and raped by more than 50 men,
some of whom she knew.
I cried when I read about the
murder of Rebecca Cheptegei,
who was set alight by an ex-partner
in front of her child.
She just returned from the Olympics.
I've covered these three cases and ones
like them for places like glamour,
Marie Claire, stylist Grazia, Women's
Health and many more.
I become a go to feminist voice in British
media, appearing on Women's Hour,
radio one five live and others.
I also have a platform called EFF Girls
Club which educates against misogyny.
Now, in doing this work, I come up against
the same label again and again.
Misandrist. Undressed. I'm
told that I hate men.
I'm told that my love for women
and marginalized genders,
and my passion for our safety,
means that I hate men.
This is categorically not true.
My feminism is also for
the benefit of boys
and men who are harmed by misogynistic
socialization,
whether or not they choose
to accept this reality.
Now, as I said, in doing this work, I have
built a bit of a public profile.
And sadly, but unsurprisingly,
this has resulted in a huge amount of
misogynistic abuse directed at me.
When a piece of my writing goes viral,
I can expect at least one death
threat a week in my DMs
and thousands of abusive messages.
My appearance picked apart, my
intelligence is questioned,
my safety threatened. So I say I know
quite a lot about misogyn.
And misandry, although it’s a
lesser known word
and some of you might not think this
sounds relevant to you. Trust me, it is.
It's become the go to clapback from
people who want to silence women
discussing misogyny and patriarchy.
They use it as an Uno reverse card,
flipping the narrative back on us
and implying that actually it's
feminists who are the problem.
So I wanted to share some
of the messages I get,
and these are the sanitized ones.
I’m often told that misogyny isn’t real.
That women have all the power nowadays.
They tell me I'm a misandrist,
and that's dangerous because more
men than women get murdered.
They don't mention that it's
men doing the murdering.
The irony is clearly lost on them
that they are partaking in
the same misogynistic violence
they claim isn't real.
It's also lost on them that fighting
misogyny leads to better educational
attainment and mental health
among boys in school.
So throughout my career, and because of
the messages I received like this,
I feel that I'm qualified to say the
following. Misandry is not a threat.
At its worst, it hurts
some men's feelings.
Misogyny, on the other hand, kills
women daily. One is a structure.
The other is a reaction. Misandry at
present is only a reaction to misogyny.
So let's look at the four B movement
in South Korea, for example.
It was born around five years ago,
and it's based on four principles where
women reject heterosexual childbirth,
marriage, dating and sexual
relationships with men.
In 2016, intimate partner violence was
recorded at 41.5% in South Korea.
This statistic makes it clear to me the
reasoning behind the four B movement.
It is a reaction to misogyny.
However, many have dubbed it as misandrist
, as a hatred of men.
This is not true. When we look at incels,
I imagine you will think about men,
right? Well, by definition, there are
also women who are involuntary celibate,
aka incels, but we call them FEM cells,
and their existence is entirely different.
Incels have become a global threat,
with many defining it as extremism
and terrorism.
In 2014, Elliot Rodger stabbed and shot
dead six people in California,
blaming girls who rejected him.
Since then, numerous incel attacks have
been carried out under this ideology.
Like Jake Davison, who in Plymouth
in 2021 murdered five people,
including his mother and
a three year old girl.
There's no concrete statistics,
but it's believed around 100 people have
been murdered under incel ideology,
mostly women and girls.
FEM sells, by contrast, have been
linked to zero murders.
They are largely non-violent and
they are not operating in
the same militarised way. One of these
things is not like the other.
Misandry is not like misogyny.
We see femme sells as the
pinnacle of misandry,
but actually many of them became femme
sells after experiencing traumatic
relationships with men, and they
felt safer just withdrawing.
So misandry has become a popular
buzzword in modern culture,
and it's been given legitimacy in academia
that has trickled down into
incel chatrooms and far
right circles online.
However, despite this, there's very few
explorations of what misandry is what
does exist. Accepts it as
the inverse of misogyny.
The dictionary definition literally
presents them as the same.
For example, there's a book called
Spreading Misandry The Teaching of
Contempt for men. In popular culture.
The authors Paul Nathanson and Katherine
Young in it say that unlike misogyny,
misandry is acceptable in society
both morally and legally.
That's laughable to me. How could anyone
say that misogyny is unacceptable in
society when it's everywhere?
It's in our homes, it's on our TVs,
it's in our newsrooms,
it's in our police forces. It's
on our social media feeds.
Misandry, by contrast, is practically
invisible both in popular culture
and the real world. But let's take their
statement and see if it's real.
Can we answer the following questions?
Can you name a country where young boys
are legally allowed to marry adult women?
Where 1 in 3 men are sexually
assaulted by a woman.
Where the majority of men are
murdered by women, not men.
Where men cannot wear what they like.
Where men cannot leave their homes
without a female chaperone.
Where women dictate what jobs
men can and cannot do.
The answer to all these questions is no.
But when we reverse it
and look at misogyny,
the answers are a harrowing
and resounding yes.
In recent years in the UK,
a woman has been killed by a man
on average every three days.
Male violence against women is a leading
cause of premature death
for women globally.
This year alone in the UK,
the number of women whose
deaths have led to
a man being charged has now exceeded 50.
The actual number will be considerably
higher. This is just who's been charged.
Between 2022 and 2023, in the
north east of England,
72% of domestic abuse victims were women.
About 90% of homicide suspects
in England and Wales are men.
So when we look at all the evidence,
the truth is,
is that women do not hate men
the way that men hate women.
Misandry is not a threat because at worst
it hurts some men's feelings.
Misogyny, on the other hand,
kills people daily.
The oppressed cannot oppress
the oppressor.
I'm not telling you all this
just to depress you.
I want you to leave today and push back
up against these unhelpful narratives
and red herrings. Because misandry
is so often brought up as
a way to distract women talking
about very real misogyny.
It is what aboutism and almost
always a red flag.
We must not equate the two things.
It invalidates and disrespects all the
people who have been abused, harmed,
murdered under misogynistic violence.
Misandry is a myth, and those who try
and drum up hysteria about it
are disinformation actors.
Thank you.
Well, thank you.